so i love this reply to one of my tweets
this week from catherine
the astonishing incompetence of
bottleneck biden exceeds our worst fears
bottleneck biden it's got a nice ring to
it let's put it on screen
you see we keep saying follow me on
twitter at steve hilton x i do actually
read what you say on there
and one of the more amusing aspects of
bottleneck biden's response to the
latest crisis of their own making
is that they're trying to claim credit
for solving it but at the same time
saying it's got nothing to do with them
the president has the the supply chain
task force has been working around the
clock for months and months now to
address a range of different issues that
we see in the supply chain let's
remember these are private sector
systems this is a capitalist country
nobody wants the federal government to
own or operate the stores the warehouses
the trucks or the ships or the ports
oh so it's the private sector's fault
it's our fault the biden regime paid
workers to stay at home raised energy
costs and impose stupid anti-science
vaccine mandates
and don't you love the quaint way pete
butterjudge talks fondly about
capitalism is someone going to tell them
the people who run his party now are
just not that into it
but the deeper problem with bottleneck
biden supply chain crisis is not that
the supply chains are disrupted but the
fact they exist in the first place for
decades the establishment in both
parties bought into the globalist
ideology that shipping jobs and
manufacturing to china was a win-win
china becomes more democratic we get
cheaper products and a lower cost of
living but china didn't get more free it
got more authoritarian the only people
better off here were the elites who
profited from the hollowing out of
america's heartland and our
manufacturing base we weakened ourselves
while strengthening our number one enemy
and now look what's happening china's
threatening an invasion of taiwan and
just today we see reports of a
nuclear-capable hypersonic missile far
more advanced than anything we thought
they had
we enabled this we made china richer so
they could invest in the technology
they're now planning to use for world
domination and when i say we i actually
mean you you bill clinton you george
bush you barack obama and you joe biden
all of you pushing the decades-long
suck-up to china the most disastrous
strategic miscalculation in modern
history
china's power is built on economic
foundations that we put there it's time
to take them away so no we should not be
rushing to fix our broken supply chain
with china it's not a supply chain it's
a noose let's cut ourselves free
decouple from china bring back jobs to
america we may not be at war with china
but they are most surely at war with us
so
let's use the trading with the enemy act
to immediately enforce a complete
economic disengagement from china hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else